[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
look the show's great literally took my
family out of poverty so I can't be mad
about come town but imagine if the
dumbest thing you've ever done is what
popped you huge you know God bless the
Adam Friedland show you know I honestly
think podcasting is I mean we're really
pulling the biggest scam of all time
over on people this is complete [ __ ]
you know what I mean like at this point
the way like media works you gotta have
something for your fans to do like every
week but I'm gonna take a long ass break
I'll probably do some kind of [ __ ]
podcast or video show or something
welcome back to episode 2 of stavy's
world it's already been 10 days since
Davy's World a brand new comedy podcast
hosted by Stavros hulkius launched their
first episode on YouTube Stavros is
quickly becoming a household name in
comedy due in large part to his weekly
crowd work clips and also the growth of
his former podcast come town which you
stepped away from back in June claiming
that he hates podcasting and was
basically only showing up to cash a
check now given that these were his
reasons for leaving come Town many of
his fans were very confused to see stuff
starting a brand new show only five
months later so I asked 160 000 comedy
fans with their thoughts on the new show
stavy's world were and in today's video
we're reading some of the best comments
and showing some clips from the show
visiting you pod you're you're part of
the like uh the experimental batch I
love what we're doing here thank you
buddy it's a i it's gonna be it's a
little like you know what if your
therapist was a a fat Greek [ __ ] who
operated out of his father's restaurant
that's kind of the vibe you know so just
to recap the timeline real quick here
styros announced that he was leaving
come town on June 5th 2022 saying I'm
sad my involvement in the Pod is over
but I'm also really excited for the
future I'm working on a couple things I
can't wait to share love you thanks for
everything come town was a very big show
with a very loyal fan base since Stavros
left they've continued on as the Adam
Friedland show and it's still a
successful podcast but the relationship
between Adam Nick and savros is still a
bit unclear Mason Connor said just
proves that he's either finally
realizing just how much money he skipped
out on due to his own laziness or
there's much more bad blood between him
and the Adam Friedland show then he'll
publicly admit Andrew Williams had
perfect guess for the Adam Friedland
show Nick said should have called it
stop town in relation to come town
obviously and then Jay stack said in
quotation marks I quit podcasting
because it didn't make me happy I was
just showing up to collect a paycheck
they're still my friends we'll hang out
and [ __ ] back to podcasting and still
hasn't gone on the Adam Friedland show
seems like the old fans of come down
definitely want him on as a guest or
just some clarity about what that
relationship is currently like how has
it been though the like the breakup
obviously people are curious but like
has are people mad at you online or oh
yeah of course yeah they were always
going to be mad yeah for sure it's been
good I mean listen it's it's all love
it's all you know you know God bless the
Adam Friedland show you know I hope
those boys are successful kind of
killing it right now it's great if I
heard the monologues I have not my dogs
are solid I'm completely off I'm
completely off everything not even you
know that show just everything so yeah
it's all like they're gonna be
successful they're hilarious as [ __ ] but
I was just like honestly dude I think
because I was at the end of this [ __ ]
tour and I was so tired I was like I
don't want to do anything and also I
talked about it's so funny because we I
was on the show and I was like dude I
hate podcasting and it was almost like
part like doing the Press run actually I
was like talking about and I was like oh
so you're put you're you're both it's
your fault I'm talking to you guys
you're like podcasting sucks no that's
fine yeah yeah this is you've been doing
you've been running like a extremely
successful podcast for six years since
you meet us for one afternoon you're
like yo this makes you want to end up
like these pieces
oh man it's cool though because you
don't have like very DieHard fans that
will totally blame us yeah man we're
fine stoppy's world comes out every
single Monday and so far as featured
guest number one Sam Morrell and guest
number two the boys from are you garbage
Kevin Ryan and H Foley there's also a
therapy slash advice portion at the end
of the show according to Stavros Stavros
and his friends help solve all your
problems call 904 800 staff and leave a
voicemail to get some advice some people
like the advice portion some people
don't Tommy Callahan said Stavros I need
some advice that's the first time those
words have ever been said Jacob Johnson
said I'm hoping it'll be like therapy
gecko meets an all-you-can-eat Greek
Buffet which honestly would be best case
scenario for this new pod I feel like if
you're coming out with a brand new show
in this day and age of the saturated
podcast Market need some sort of twist
some sort of angle to make your show
stand out and comedians helping people
solve their problems live on the show
Stavros and friends that could be the
perfect new Lane for him to step into
and really make this thing pop okay
um
I've got a situation
I've got like uh I'm talking to like
three girls right now
and I don't know I don't know how to how
to uh resolve this issue no he's not
before it goes live
because I'm gonna have to like pick one
I guess
but I have too much human emotion to
turn people down oh my God how do I not
uh want to kill myself you know what I
mean pause this for a second before we
listen to it appreciate appreciate it
I'm furious
no go ahead I guess finish it buddy pal
love from uh Atlanta and by Atlanta I
mean a racist town 45. okay this guy
[ __ ] stinks
into I [ __ ] a perfect 10 the other
night and she was like Sam you're the
best and I was like Jesus
it makes me so sad to accept confidence
without giving them
um basically you [ __ ] too much and
you're upset that you have to choose one
of the women you [ __ ] too much
and you're gonna hurt two other I mean
like yeah grow up my [ __ ] is so good I'm
gonna I'm gonna deprive two women of it
though when I choose one and I have too
much empathy I'm too much of a human
being that you I mean this is like
there's not a line in this it isn't a
brag no this yeah everything about and
and even his whole manner and look this
is the first time this has ever happened
to this guy right that's what we're
dealing with here this is a man that
does not understand has never gotten
[ __ ] at this level you're hot right now
this is the best it's ever gonna get
don't think like this is going to be a
problem forever for the rest of your
life this is the only time but in fact
he called what a week ago this is a
situation already over if I had to guess
two of these women have fought at least
one of them is not returning your calls
by now already definitely not by the
time this [ __ ] episode airs you have
no problems just pick one this is what
this is what dating is you got hot and
you called in to brag [ __ ] you suck my
dick yeah call back and you know what
you pulled up from 40 and you shot an
air ball you ain't Steph Curry you're
Seth Curry and you and you're playing
well yeah you're a girl you're a good
player
if you ain't got Rings that's right
that's right you are Seth Curry and for
a moment this is like yeah this is like
when a role player has that one crazy
game and he's like 35 in the playoffs
yeah yeah he's like I guess I'm a Max
contract guy you're not you're exactly
who you are enjoy well last call back I
bet you this is a situation that's blown
up in your face uh just by how
ill-equipped you are for it
um next question eldest that one that
one put me in a bad mood that one the
biggest debate in this comment section
wasn't even about the new podcast or why
he left the old podcast it was about
stavros's laugh this guy said who's he
going to obnoxiously laugh at if he's by
himself the main reason I never listen
to most full episodes of come town was
his laugh plenty of Clips so I lost
about five minutes with the Sam episode
and I love Sam M and Dustin Murphy said
Steve's laugh is absolutely wonderful
the only comedian that may have a better
one is Ryan sickler Lisa is a good one
too Stavros has been called his own
personal laugh track many times in
comment sections he has this thing where
he's on stage or in a podcast and he's
been known just to burst out in laughter
after something that he says which I get
why people can find it annoying it's
like the old Seinfeld episodes with
laugh track sometimes it just takes away
from the joke but in soft's case I
actually find it endearing first of all
it's his own signature style it's a
unique thing about him it's very Stavros
you know it's his laugh it's distinct
the other thing is he never uses it to
like cover up bombs it's not like what
he's saying isn't funny he usually
laughs after something hilarious that he
says or someone else says you've been
with your parents I moved in with no you
know what I did man
um where did you go I have her after
that I had a really good uh tight group
of friends from high school and my one
buddy was kind of like a nutritionist
and all that kind of stuff and uh you
guys have lost touch since no no no no
no no no no
[Laughter]
besides the people that were still a
little pissed off at Stavros for leaving
his former podcast just to start a brand
new one months later there are also some
commenters basically rolling their eyes
at the thought of any new podcast in
general this guy said I'll listen might
get to the point where it depends on the
guest too many people to keep up with
and eventually the well is going to run
thin with guests doing their rounds his
scripted crowd work wasn't enough so now
it's on the scripted podcast more power
to him there are definitely some people
that eat this up is this really a thing
with his crowd work that people think
it's scripted I've never heard of that
how would you even how would you even do
that like he travels with a plant to
every show and have he has him say like
a ridiculous occupation or sexual fetish
that he can comment written jokes on I
don't even know how you would fake crowd
work really on a world tour but I could
be wrong I guess Jose said way too main
podcasts to listen to so no thanks I'll
keep listening to the same two podcasts
ain't nobody got time for that
I totally relate to this it really does
feel like there's just too many podcasts
to listen to sometimes it just is like a
confusing and frustrating and hell even
depressing feeling to be overwhelmed by
this fast-paced podcast lifestyle that
everyone lives in nowadays but luckily
there's a joke World comedy update every
single Monday bringing you all the
comedy news that you need to know from
your favorite podcasts your favorite
comedians literally anything happening
in the comedy world all on one show
every Monday one YouTube channel this
one the one you're already on click
subscribe and post notifications turn
those on and boom you've done it you can
listen to all the podcasts you'll get
updates on who went on each other shows
new specials coming out anything
happening in the comedy World hell last
Tuesday we interviewed Mark Norman live
on the comedy news on this channel what
else do you need comedy turn it on post
notifications now subscribe
sorry if that was aggressive I just it
was cool to Loop these comments back
into our own main show here right
you guys did not see that coming
well here's another ad picture this
you're lounging around at home doing
your thing but you don't want to wear
sweats because you'll look like a giant
toddler you want something super soft
and super comfortable yet smart enough
for that unexpected Zoom call or
unwanted visitor or picture this one
it's hot it's real hot and you're at the
beach or you're by the pool going in and
out of the water but don't want to be
getting your clothes wet that's really
not a good look being wet on land
looking sweatier than prince Andrew at a
playground the answer to both these
scenarios is apply a London plus small
shirt these are the world's first plush
Mouse shirts meaning they're all 100
super thin super soft organic toweling
cotton perfect for long days at the
beach traveling lounging around super
absorbent no sweat marks do yourself a
favor and go check out Playa London
today also as I was making this video
today Stavros announced on Instagram
that the staffies world patreon is now
up and running with bonus episode number
one being with guest Ian Finance thank
you so much for watching this video
please let me know in the comments what
you think of savvy's world go follow us
on Instagram if you want to support the
channel we'll give you some free joke
World stickers and also just a quick
update to everyone who's DMS on
Instagram looking to get the free joke
World stickers first of all thank you so
much and I'm not upset about this I'm
not complaining about this but rdms were
flooded like it's just just too much to
go for it's completely I would never be
able to make videos like this and
respond to the DMS it's almost a
full-time job in those DMS right now so
the new way to claim your joke World
stickers your free joke World stickers
is there's a link in the Instagram bio
that says stickers you fill out that
Google form with your name and your
address and your email and we'll make
sure to get these to you in the mail as
soon as possible and also just for the
people that have been filling out the
form make sure you include your full
address because some of you are just
putting random streets street names and
numbers with no state or city or zip
code involved I don't know what you want
me to do with that but it's I do want
you to get your stickers so make sure
you're doing your full address your full
information so these do get you in the
mail and if you've already dm'd Us in
the past and haven't received them yet
it's because our DMS are completely
[ __ ] so you got to go redo it I'm
sorry to make you type your address in
like two or three different times if
you've already dm'd but this is the only
way forward it's a good sign I mean in
the grand scheme of things is a great
problem to have so thank you all so much
for the support thank you for watching
this video let me know what you think of
stavy's world and I'll see you go
I see and I'll see you guys
and I'll see you guys on Monday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]